[Musique]
C'est une zone super super polluée Mais
cela n'affecte pas les populations de
crocodiles les crocodiles pour leur
capacités évolutives pour leur
les conditions physiologiques ont le
capacité à résister à cela tout à fait
pollution
comme je leur dis évolutivement ils ne le font pas
ils n'ont eu à rien varier et pour leur
capacités de coagulation grâce à ses
capacité à se régénérer après
un accident qu'ils peuvent parfaitement
être dans cette rivière malgré le
conditions de contamination qui
a
ici on essaie de
nettoyer les pneus de ramassage
ramasser du plastique mais nous n'obtenons rien
Oui Ici en train de sortir toutes ces ordures Oui le
d'en haut continuent de polluer
[Musique]
au Costa Rica a été consacrée à la
création de lois à la création de
réglementation à la création de décrets
essayez de penser que si nous retournons tout
normatif c'est ainsi que le problème est résolu et
la réalité est que la norme ne va pas
résoudre le problème qui doit
changer essentiellement à ce que sont les
les gens avec leurs actions qui est le
même gouvernement avec ses dispositions avec
la création d'une véritable politique
public dirigé par
complète à la protection de la vie
Sauvage
[Musique]